we do have a new uh move in the final
yes and we did see a set of rooks leave
the board
so rooks have been traded and black
planting a night in the middle there
um just such sensible logical staff
knights of fantastic pieces in the
middle of the board
black's knight now attacks the white
rook as well where will
white's rook run to there aren't that
many safe squares actually levon aronian
went down to three seconds when he
played that move
to white rook that is depressing that's
the
move he would not have enjoyed playing
no i mean it's on the same diagonal
as the black bishop so i would be
looking at pushing a pawn
yep um logical but white's rook forced
itself back to the corner
blocked off by its own pawn and um if we
bring up the analysis board briefly we
can just see this bishop um
black's problem piece is this bishop
this bishop cannot move so why not push
a pawn forward
suddenly unleashing this bishop he's
done it this bishop
i mentioned earlier as soon as it joins
the game black will win so white tries
to block this diagonal
block the bishop off the white knight
also giving check i expect to see that
piece just captured just remove that
piece from the board
black edging closer to victory now he
doesn't have to worry about this piece
being dominated anymore
okay wow now timor java is thinking he's
still
far up on the clock um with his
uh last move the rook move yes so we did
see the dart square bishop black star
square bishop
which was just completely completely
just chained up for the whole game it's
finally been traded off so
black has got rid of his problem child
his problem piece and the black rook
activating itself as well the first time
that
rook has moved um rajab doing the right
thing he's a porn up he's using all of
his pieces together all of black's
pieces have
pretty much centralized now um raj above
also centralizing the white bishop
um timor rajab he just needs to find a
winning plan i think
it will come down to the fact that black
has a three versus one advantage
on that left side um that being said
there are opposite colored bishops on
the board white has a dark square bishop
black has a light squared bishop so if
the knights disappear
if the rooks disappear maybe that's
white's best chance of saving the game
that's something that lavon has to hope
for
yeah i agree with you david he has to
find a way it's
kind of i have to say it is a little
slightly tricky kind of position because
there is there is no kind of clear plan
because he's there is a plan of pushing
the far advanced pawn
but rajabov hasn't prepared for that
he's put his rook against
the white pawn in the center and if he
advances the king
then he's going to give levon a free
move such as a check a night check and
that that might be a little bit
unpleasant
so i think this is why we see uh rajabov
just
uh make a move just move the night
and again ask lavon ironian hey
what are you going to play next what are
you going to do with 15 seconds left on
the clock and
um i i know the computer there we do see
the evaluation bar it does say plus 4
for black
that is a huge advantage but it isn't so
easy on the board
black still needs to come up with a
winning plan until you find that plan
it's not clear whether you will be able
to break through or not so i disagree
with the computer that the advantage is
that big
but it is with best play um if both
players had one hour on the clock then
rajabov he would win this game
it's not easy to come up with a plan
though with one minute left and black's
plan timo rodger bob's plan is to plant
a knight in the middle of the board
there
deep in the white camp that's the second
time he's done this he did this two
games ago as well he put his knight
deep in the enemy deep in aronian's
position
lavon has only five seconds okay he just
made it with six seconds
left so he has well also re-centered
his knight to attack the white the black
bishop
and uh that is why rajo of retreated the
bishop he's like i'm not gonna give
black any easy moves whatsoever what and
uh well aronian is just making moves
yeah so the white kings does step
forward um slightly improving the king
but i think it's just time for black to
start improving his rook now the black
rook
can enter an open line um okay
you see it there and uh again aronian
plane
quickly trying to recreate though he's
not happy
uh he i mean normally he tries to keep
that poke face i've played him and
losing when he's losing
and he tries to keep that poker face but
he knows now things are going against
him black's
last move using his black knight and the
black bishop
to gang up on white's corner porn there
the white pawn on the left
it is doomed it's attacked twice it's
only defended once
that pawn is soon going to disappear
also black's knight is potentially
threatening some
forks some night jumps aronian down to
one
and shaking his head again he is not
happy live on ironian
it is now timorou in the move he's
leaned back
yeah and it's uh it's a sad sight to see
that levon he's got
nothing better to do than trade a set of
rooks when
actually we've mentioned it before you
don't want to trade when you're down on
pawns
necessarily and um yeah i think raj
above he'll welcome that rook trade
um he'll just go after white's pawn at
the corner there
yeah you can see him doing it there he
has played a check the king has
retreated
and i think i'm going to see like knight
takes bishop
and i think i think uh raja buff will
just get greedy
three pawns on the left that is and that
is seriously good
yeah and the knight does capture the
bishop um he's just simplifying his own
task he's just eliminating
all risk if he can oh he's
mean this is me so efficient
so instead of grabbing the pawn which is
like i couldn't take that any time he's
like well you know what
there's some annoying pawns on the right
hand side and the center
let's just get rid of those ones first
and uh that is a double attack and chess
is all about double attacks black's rook
eyeing up two of white's pawns there
irony and he's got nothing else to do
other than trying to attack one of the
black pawns but remember black's already
one point up
all of white's remaining pawns are weak
another one drops
black's temporarily two pawns up um he
will be two pawns up in this game and
notice
um now all of white's pawns are on light
squares on white squares so there'll be
easy meat
easy pickings for that uh for the black
bishop um black's bishop
will win all those remaining pawns um
levon aroni he's just making moves
because he doesn't want to resign yet
and okay nobody's ever won a game by
resigning but
um he knows that there's nothing left to
do in this game
you can just see it on his body language
yes the monaro onion is
giving up very soon yeah and he has
resigned
there we have it rajabov has won the
first match
wow okay such a tense day we had three
draws
and then coming to the final game of the
first
final match timorajabo is the winner of
that and that means he is the winner
of day one in the finals and they are
keeping calm we can see it on the
webcams now both players
but what's going on inside the the heads
now you won't go
well i think lavone will be so
disappointed you know i think he'll
check
through the lines and just see where he
went wrong but yeah he will be feeling
frustrated because
he was so close to a draw and ultimately
it was his
eagerness to push forward really hard
for the wind that kind of backfired on
him
and uh after three games with those
draws david
uh what happened in this final game
where sort of
uh a lot the tension was sort of
released and we did
for a long time see uh so much drama on
the board
yeah a lot of drama we saw level one
aronian pushing
throwing everything at the wind there
actually he could have even repeated the
position at one point but he played for
the win and
we liked his position we don't blame him
for playing for that win but
it was just this one decision he uh that
he made that cost him
long term um we love white's pawns here
white's pawns especially on this right
side
look at those four pawns so strong
gaining so much space
and backed up nicely and that's an
important factor backed up nicely by
white's pieces
but he maybe pushed the wrong pawn he
put his pawn on a dark square
these two pawns now actually block in
white's bishop
also on dark squares and we saw a few
moves later that
um timor rajabov as black was able to
blockade these pawns
as soon as black got his bishop to this
blockading square suddenly
what is this white bishop doing it's
just blocked in completely
by his own pawns the pawns can never
move anymore remember black was also a
pawn up at this stage and
um once he made this blockade timor
rajabov he never let contr
let go of control he just traded off the
right pieces he eventually picked off
white sweet pawns and
from there it was all downhill for
iranian